[Music]
criminal activity has become part of
China's strategy to grow its power in
conjunction with its authoritarian
statecraft i
y uh a woman named Ying Chan Wang and a
man named Steven hoe they don't around
and they're not going to take your p no
one's going to see
you we knew going out that he said that
he didn't want to come back Oklahoma
he'd be dead if he come back to
[Music]
Oklahoma what you just saw is a small
preview of the result of countless hours
uh of in-depth reporting open source
research and undercover work that was
directly informed by your exclusive tips
now what we've discovered
here was a series of clandestine foreign
actors collaborating on United States
soil in the Realms of drugs human
trafficking murder Espionage and it's
not the plot of a mission impossible
movie fortunately everyone's least
favorite Scientologist is nowhere to be
found what you're about to
see is a true story of how International
organized crime connected to one of the
most powerful governments in the world
that's
foreshadowing has taken over Middle
America and how it threatens to do the
same across the entire United
[Music]
[Applause]
States
[Music]
in 2018 Oklahoma legalized the medical
use of marijuana after a Statewide
referendum passed with
57% of the vote now pause let me be
clear here this piece has nothing to do
with whether you're against cannabis
legalization whether you're for it
whether you partake or are menonite this
is about the unintended or fully
intended Fallout as it relates to
American land owners taxpayers and the
Communist Chinese government few quick
numbers for you since July 2021 the
state has collected over 155 million do
in marijuana related tax revenue now
we've all heard for decades and I once
believed this too that legalizing or
decriminalizing drugs uh would eliminate
the black
market in Oklahoma the exact opposite
has happened there has been an
unprecedented number of illegal
operations grow Farms growing at rates
breaking records completely unseen
before the real problem is the owners
and the players milking this cash cow
for all it's worth at your expense
basically think less Jeff Spicoli you
dick and more communist Tyrant El Chapo
now the implications go far beyond state
or even National borders and they
constitute a full-blown threat to
America's national security to put it
simply this may surprise a lot of people
Oklahoma is the weed capital of the
United States no not Colorado not
California not even New York Oklahoma
which has forced them to change their
state motto to more than just tornadoes
and chaps here are a few more numbers to
show you uh just how much of a weed
Haven Oklahoma actually is uh
2,683 dispensaries in Oklahoma this is
the most in the nation and more than
double the number located in the number
two state California twice the
dispensaries of California 844 million
grams of cannabis packaged in Oklahoma
in 2023 that's 64 times the amount that
consumers in Oklahoma could possibly
need
4617 that's the number of active Growers
just in 2024 and that's only exceeded by
California with
5,491 at its peak Oklahoma had nearly
14,000 licenses the point is lot of cash
lot of HC one grower who asked to remain
anonymous due to his ongoing involvement
uh in the state's cannabis industry laid
out exclusively to mug Club undercover
here why he was attracted to Oklahoma
even without the chaps we real cheap the
license the the barrier to entry was
$2,500 which I mean looking back on it
now any any person that sells any kind
of drugs can come up with that to get a
legal license uh which we've seen a lot
of but uh it was very D was cheap you
know land I paid like six grand for 2
and2 Acres wow uh yeah it's nothing you
know I mean it's just very very cheap
out here and this was going to kind of
be our American Dream you know this was
me getting away from having new physical
labor this was us having a family
business with my dad um and it just
didn't it didn't turn out that way but
yeah what brought us down it was just so
cheap was so affordable for a blue
collar person to be able to do it so
it's a new go Rush as it were filled
with absolutely baked Prospectors but
make no mistake those seeking to take
advantage of the conditions on the
ground include a lot of less than
scrupulous actors and there is one
specific group that has taken particular
advantage of Oklahoma's
relaxed chill industry
[Music]
standards China as it turns out the only
thing that these Chinese Nationals like
more than the marijuana industry in the
United States is Hollywood movie posters
this is for the movie poster they
actually they removed Chewbacca this
character seems to be in the Forefront
like he is the
centerpiece but here they depict him
turned around right he's not he's not
even looking towards the audience so
right here and if you didn't know about
this there's actually there's a story
out there about this character and uh
the the race and gender swap it's as a
thought experiment watch Star Wars again
and tell me the Empire is not literally
exactly the same as the Chinese
government and to the surprise of
absolutely no one in the history of
Earth ever frequently these Chinese
Nationals are involved in wait for it
highly illegal activity focused
primarily on the black market the
Chinese involvement in the marijuana
industry is so extensive that officials
note it's actually more surprising if
you encounter an illegal operation
without connections to China of the 800
Farms shut down from 2021 to 2023
75% were linked directly to China here's
Oklahoma Bureau of Narcotics
spokesperson Mark Woodward talking with
us exclusively outlining the specific
practices that Chinese crime
organizations you've heard of the Triads
how they infiltrate the industry you
would look over a fence and and it's not
two or three local guys growing
marijuana like we've seen for the first
couple of years it would be 50 what
would appear to be Asian uh Chinese
workers which is not a problem as long
as they're not you know violating any
laws sure but when we would start
getting
calls that uh from law enforcement out
of state saying that we just intercepted
a truckload of marijuana the driver says
it came off of so and so Farm in
Oklahoma and we would start
investigating that farm and sure enough
it was one of these Chinese operated
Farms where all the workers were Chinese
but yet the the owner is listed as a
certain person and it turns out that
person is a secretary in a law office so
you're kind of going okay what's going
on here um and so we started looking
into what's behind the ownership who are
these people and and what we started to
realize and one of the things that was
written into Oklahoma's law that's
fairly unique it said 75% of your
ownership has to be somebody who's been
an Oklahoma resident for 2 years well
obviously that's a problem for a
criminal organization linked to Chinese
organized crime that's been growing in
the northern California desert you know
for the last eight years supplying Black
Market marijuana to to Flushing New York
now before we get to the the real crimes
this one's just kind of annoying it's a
dick move they often steal massive
amounts of water electricity leading to
shortages for the local community it's a
crappy thing to do but but it's not as
bad as um The coldblooded
Killing yeah that's exemplified by the
quadruple murder of four Chinese workers
on a marijuana Farm in king fisher
County Oklahoma in November 2022 a
search is ongoing for a quadruple murder
suspect in Kingfisher County four bodies
were found last night at a 10 acre
marijuana Grove Farm as another person
is hospitalized with injuries law
enforcements deployed massive resources
in that search for the alleged attacker
the ECT who was eventually apprehended
in Florida was a 45-year-old male named
Chen Wu with the most predictable mug
shot ever he showed up on the farm
demanding he immediately be paid 300,000
as repayment for his investment in the
operation I've got to be very careful
because it's still under investigation
the investigating agency but from what
we can gather this this Chinese
individual male showed up at the farm uh
was demanding money that he felt he and
or others maybe in an investment group
were were owed and had orders that if
they don't pay they're going to be kill
them because these are just workers they
can replace those workers and when they
said we don't have the money um he
started shooting them one at a time
ended up killing four of them a fifth
person escaped and managed to notify
authorities most of the time though they
will not leave a witness like a
communist Chinese Warren Buffett now
he's been charged with four counts of
first-degree murder and one count
assault and battery
with a deadly weapon which when you
think about it that's the four counts of
murder really should tie that up with a
bow but we'll toss in assault and
battery while we're at it now in a Twist
turn of Fate the Survivor from Woo's
murder spree actually ended up at the
same Oklahoma
jail where W was being held and we were
actually able to talk with Ken Thompson
a lieutenant at the king fisher County
Sheriff's Office to hear a little bit
more about about this specific case
myself and another depy actually went
down to Florida to Miami dat and picked
up the shooter and brought him back from
from Miami dat oh yeah I heard that he
was him back up I heard he was very
hesitant to come back to Oklahoma
because he thought he was going to get
killed it was he was a weird deal of
course we knew we knew going out that he
said that he didn't want to come back to
Oklahoma he'd be dead if he come back to
Oklahoma and it was really weird because
there's a um we got I mean he was
cordial the whole time he didn't speak a
lot of English but but uh but you know
we got him out we got him out for the
bathroom and we got and we fed him on
the way back and stuff like that and he
just sat back there
quietly our last guas stop was Weber
Falls once we crossed into
Oklahoma and you couldn't Proby out of
the vehicle wow it's like he knew that
he was in Oklahoma and there was no way
he was getting out of that car I said
you'll be all right we're we're here and
he's like no no I'm like okay so so he
left him in the car were you ever
contacted or were you ever in contact
with anybody in China to your knowledge
like government officials Embassy things
like that somebody there were a couple
of guys that stopped in dispatch one day
that I think that said that they the 911
Center that said that they were
connected to the Chinese Embassy and
they were referred to the OSBI and the
murders don't stop in King Fisher County
or as it's known by some namely when a
good County to murder according to Mr
Woodward of the obn they've actually
become quite common all over the state
we've seen others uh on a on not quite
that scale but certainly homicides have
been something that we've seen a lot of
uh linked to to marijuana since 2020
when when we really saw the black market
uh migrate to our state now when we ask
the same local grower uh we showed you
earlier why local authorities were so
powerless to stop these illegal actions
by Chinese Nationals like murder he
claimed it was because the cops were on
the take I've spoken with a couple law
enforcement officials from Oklahoma and
they act like they have a handle on it
they're like well we're shutting down a
bunch of these we've my wife laughing at
you in the background she heard you say
that I didn't say hey this isn't from me
this is from law enforcement I'm not
that's the funniest thing we've heard
yet the police actually rule Oklahoma
are all on the C now to be clear we
don't any proof to back that claim up
and according to the official statistics
from the Oklahoma Bureau of Narcotics
they've cut the number of grow farms in
the state from
94221 to 3200 in 2023 so do with that uh
what you will and the king fisher County
Sheriff's Department was really pretty
helpful with us in our investigation so
thanks to them however it it does seem
that nearly every week There's a report
of a new grow operation being raided so
clearly there's a problem going on our
team here supported by viewers Like You
by the way thank you actually visited uh
the site of one of these illegal grow
operations that was shut down in Carter
County Oklahoma in December
2023 all right we are out here just
north of Hilton Oklahoma that's about
halfway between the border and Oklahoma
City at the site of a shutdown illicit
marijuana farm that was taken down by
the Bureau of Narcotics last month and
on the property they found over 11,000
plants which is about 300 lb of
marijuana now uh this is 46-year-old
Jimmy Deng that was arrested in
connection with this often times what
happens and what he's pending charges
for um is something called straw
ownership where the company is set up by
someone in Oklahoma ostensively but
often times it's someone that's out of
state or a foreign National that's
running this these type of organizations
now there's a lot of problems here and I
I don't say this
lightly these people are responsible for
things like sex trafficking human
trafficking illegal narcotic sale across
state borders whatever they're finding
fentanyl they're finding ketamine murder
in king fisher County
right maybe the worst thing and not the
worst thing but something that's really
going to get it you is this man just
left a million dogs out here abandoned
right like this little guy completely
abandoned and I mean it's not a human
but still who's going to take care of
him clearly there is no responsibility
there and mama's over here yeah I know I
know and
I mean it is a dog but this shows you
how little these people care
because here's Mama's puppy right here
completely dead because some idiot
decided he wanted to run drugs by the
way all the references are available in
the description or at lc.com and I
encourage you to check them out so now
that you know Middle America is being
taken over by murderous International
crime
organizations of largely people small in
stature where are they all coming from
how are they getting
[Music]
here so to set the stage here in
December 2023 the southern border of the
United States so an all-time record of
302,000 known Crossings and while a bulk
of those are from places like Central
America you've got vene vuela a not so
insignificant number are coming from
let's say China China China China China
China China China China China
China in 2023 at least 25,000 people
illegally crossed from China and that's
more than the previous 10 years combined
a long line of Chinese migrants make
their way to the us through its border
with
Mexico they arrived after a treacherous
journey through a route in Panama that
has become increasingly
[Music]
popular and this is why an open borders
policy is not compassionate it is the
opposite of compassionate these people
are not dreamers just trying to get here
seeking a better life to get a glimpse
at the Statue of Liberty a lot of these
Chinese migrants they arrive here in the
United States with extensive debt either
owed to Smugglers that help them Reach
the United States or to parties back in
China with connections very often
directly the Communist Chinese
government and it makes them a perfect
Target for the organized crime leaders
here in the United States at these
Chinese Grove farms to victimize we have
absolutely uh intercepted individuals
that have come straight to Oklahoma uh
from China across the the border that
have been smuggled in here and that's
why so much of them uh are willing to
work in horrible conditions because and
that's that's where they get into the
labor traffic because many of them are
now paying off this debt quote unquote
they're they're constantly reminded
remember we smuggled you into this
country we we put up U you know we we
put a lot on the line for you say now
you got to work off this debt well guess
what that debt never ends and that's for
females and males and that's how a lot
of these females get involved in
prostitution and a lot of these males
end up working on marijuana farms for
deplorable conditions and are scared to
death to say anything because at least
they've got a job and the hopes of being
able to send money back home to their
families so yes absolutely they're
pouring across the border with the
specific uh task of hooking up to a
marijuana farm and working quote unquote
this debt off for these people that help
smuggle them in here but they just
simply smuggled slave labor uh so they
can maximize their profits working on
these
Farms
slaves let's be clear about that
slaves there are more slaves right now
on Earth than ever in recorded history
history did you know that than
ever because of situations like this
slaves say it do something about it
people who want to teach that America is
uniquely responsible for the evil of
slavery historically as though it
doesn't exist across the globe and it's
still happening today in the United
States in these
situations because of the fact that
people who are paid to represent us
don't enforce their own laws now we also
spoke with the Oklahoma junior Senator
uh Mark Wayne Mullen or at least his
office and they confirmed that there is
a significant concern regarding the
influx of uh Chinese migrants at the
border this is China taking advantage
knowing that they can be facilitating
both drugs and Personnel across the
southern border and Oklahoma doesn't get
talked about a whole lot uh necessarily
in the Border conversation but they
should because Texas of course is always
under the gun now of course these
Chinese migrants slash often uh slaves
or indentured
servants if your white guilt gets the
better of you they don't always come
directly through the Border uh often
times they're actively recruited from
other cities like Los Angeles or New
York and after a little digging we were
actually able to locate some of these
job postings here are a couple of
examples of the recruitment ads luring
Chinese workers to
Oklahoma Farm recruitment requires
diligence quickness and no fuss
experienced people will be given
priority Oklahoma regular Farm urgent
recruitment pause if someone specifies
regular Farm it's not a regular
Farm able to endure hardships and stand
hard work quick at work without fuss
responsible good hygiene novice or
experienced male workers are welcome now
in both of these ads first off they
really have a thing about fussing so so
if you want to be a Chinese slave
working at a grow Farm fussing is it
can't be in your wheelhouse uh but they
also listed compensation as negotiable
and applicants were given this directive
when contacting please say you are in
saw it on the American jobs website and
that last one in my opinion is too broad
is it Craigslist is it task rabbit or is
it Chinese slave.com
luckily for us they both included phone
numbers so we decided to give them a
call and see exactly what it was that
they were offering with no fuss mind you
I saw your job listing on American jobs
Network recruiting Farm Workers for
Oklahoma is this the correct
number oh no right now we got people
working now oh okay do do you know
anybody else that's hiring right now I
have a bunch of people looking for
work uh I don't know I'm
sorry okay
well are you sure it's for a job in
Oklahoma I have some people that may be
interested uh no I'm not Hing people oh
are is this American job
network
nojo no no no no
sus two things here one that's
convenient two they clearly had
absolutely no idea what we were talking
about due to the severe almost comical
Chinese accent which by the way you've
noticed I haven't done once here which
is really hard because I want to do it
and these people are criminals now one
reason they might not have wanted white
Americans to know uh what they're up to
is you know these recruiting agencies
are basically sending workers into slave
labor camps
our source though on the ground and Mr
Woodward at obn both spoke on this with
the Chinese people it's it's a few that
run everything and everyone else is is
living very very hard lives um you know
where I went where I did Consulting they
had 60 green houses and they put one
family per Greenhouse to run it each
family had a 10x 10 room that's parents
kids children all lived in a 10 by I've
seen these rooms some didn't have floors
with raw Sho running under them one
bathroom for 15 families they have one
dining hall they'll go out into the
woods someone shoot a wild hog a girl
hog they'll cook that up in a big walk
with rice and feat everybody is this
essentially a human trafficking
operation by other means also well for
the boots on the ground the true Farms
themselves it's slave labor so they see
it as you know these people will get
paid we talk to them once we serve
search Wars on these farms and through
interpreters some of them will say they
haven't been paid yet they're being told
I'll be paid once I you know once once
our farm makes a profit they're living
in sometimes 16 men in one mobile home
with no running water working Plumbing
um it just absolutely deplorable
conditions
but sadly through interpreters they say
I'm happy they won't complain because
they say through interpreters this is a
step up you should see how my family's
living back in China so that breaks your
heart these are victims themselves but
they won't complain and so we can't
often times file trafficking or labor
trafficking on them but yes absolutely
it's slave labor for these farms and if
that isn't bad enough the trafficking
operations of course aren't just limited
to to Farm Workers anytime you have
human trafficking it involves sex
trafficking Oklahoma law enforcement
often uh finds these brothel in more
upscale neighborhoods throughout the
state do you get into the sex
trafficking too though because there's
also a lot of Asian female specifically
China and Japanese that were brought in
into this to cater to these workers and
so we have identified underground uh
Asian brothel that operated out of
residential locations in Oklahoma where
through these underground websites they
would bring in workers from and not
typically the the marijuana workers
themselves but more the managers and
administrators of these FS the people
with real money uh they would come into
these houses in multi-million dollar
neighborhoods um for for prostitution
and ketamine we're intercepting a lot of
ketamine which is really big in Chinese
culture um we've seized more ketamine
out of since Oklahoma legalized
marijuana uh than we had in my previous
you know 28 years with our agency and
it's because of that Chinese culture so
these brothel where where there where
there's ketamine trafficking and sex
trafficking and we talked to some of
those women when we serve search
warrants and they absolutely said we are
victims we we are not willing
participants and we have been able to
get some of those females help now this
may come as a surprise uh the world of
International narcotics and sex
trafficking isn't all Glitz and glamour
it does come with some hoops to jump
through financial legal and a lot of
these prospective entrepreneurs uh do so
now here we have Bill Jones the
California Department of cannabis
controls chief of law enforcement it's a
really difficult title bil you got to
shorten it he said in a March uh
Politico article these organizations I
can't overstate how much effort they
take to layer or protect their identity
you don't have heads of the Chinese or
Mexican cartels buying these properties
lucky for them they have plenty of
[Music]
help so some credit here a lot of the
inspiration that led to us investigating
this story uh came from our tip line uh
through a journalist in Maine named
Steve Robinson now Mr Robinson is work
working on a similar story of Chinese
Nationals taking over the wheat industry
in in Maine during his research he
noticed that a lot of mortgages to the
Maine grow Farms were provided by New
York headquartered Quantic Bank among
their many services Quantic lists on
their website uh specific financing to
help foreign Nationals acquire
us property according to their own
description our foreign national
mortgage loans may be the perfect home
financing solution for non US citizens
looking to invest in us real estate we
assess your overall Financial profile
not limiting your chances due to
paperwork or documentation obstacles you
know like the
law nice nice nice nice nice and then
what do you think this is the
Indianapolis 500 knock it off we were
lucky enough to speak with Mr Robinson
and uh learn a little more about how
Quantic initially appeared on his radar
yeah so I think this this all really
started in August when the Daily Caller
news Foundation uh reported on a leaked
memo it was uh really just a some a
picture that someone took of an email
that had circulated amongst a border
patrol Department of Homeland Security
that said that there were uh 270 or more
uh illegal Chinese marijuana growing
facilities operating in the state of
Maine when the memo came out it didn't
have any details about where these
properties might be
uh but I communicated with uh Jenny T
the reporter who uh uh broke that memo
and she actually came up here to do some
firstand investigating and we took the
properties that were on uh a I guess a
partial list that she got uh maybe 12
different addresses and we pulled the
deed information from the uh the County
registry office just to see who the uh
property belonged to and one thing we
noticed based on looking at those was
that this same bank was popping up over
and over again and it's Quantic Bank
naturally we wanted to see if these
bastards had any footprint in Oklahoma
spoiler they do these bastards do they
certainly do now our search of Oklahoma
public records turned up a slew of
results for Quantic mostly mortgages on
Rural properties these properties are
located all over the states here's an
example this property in homy Oklahoma
sits on a 47 acre lot in the middle of
nowhere Prairie views open Land good for
sex trafficking I don't know 47 acres is
your oyster these other two located in
seol and SE possess what seem to be uh
already massive greenh houses perfect
for your tomato
hobby or
narcotics and unwilling prostitutes this
property and how has three massive
storage facilities that would make for
perfect grow houses and this Ranch House
in stoud which doesn't stand out other
than the fact that the buyer of the
property comes from Queens New York now
remember earlier when Mark Woodward from
the Oklahoma Bureau of Narcotics told us
that most of the heads of these illegal
grows came from Flushing New York
Flushing in a neighborhood where where
is ding ding ding
Queens so the same bank that lent money
to Illegal Mar an growers in mainee also
lent to borrowers in Oklahoma including
those from Flushing Queens The Hub of
China's illegal weed Empire in the
United States now that's compelling I
would say but that's me Mr traditional
it doesn't stop there following up
further on the main wires reporting we
cross referenced Quantic Oklahoma
mortgage documents for the name Ying
Chan Wang real name don't get mad at me
Ying Chan Wang who along with another
man named Steve St ho real name signed
off on a majority of the loans in Maine
now what did we find nearly all of
quantic's Oklahoma mortgages with
Chinese names were signed off by Wang or
ho again with Wang appearing on most of
them Wang is a loan officer at quantic's
aoria headquarters now she earned her
master's degree in public affairs at the
University of Texas but but attended
undergraduate at Jiang hope I'm saying
that correctly but I don't care
university in hangu a city on the
eastern coast of her native China Shi
Chang University close enough like most
in China of course has strong if not
direct ties to the Chinese Communist
party in 2004 the China's people
Liberation Army right the pla posted an
ad specifically at the University on
their website to recruit people for unit
61 398 a hacking and Espionage arm of
said pla in 2017 visiting Scholars from
the University formed a Communist Party
cell at UC San Diego to discuss XI Shing
Ping's speeches and it was hard to
distinguish them from other communist
groups at said University we could tell
by the height
now do we know this is Wang a CCP spy we
can't make that claim but we can say
according to one official statement
she's on the radar of Oklahoma
authorities now wanting to give her a
chance to explain things for herself we
decided to give Miss Wang a call
quantic's name is now appearing on
mortgages in Oklahoma that are suspected
of being elicit marijuana operations and
unfortunately your name and Mr Ho's name
uh Steven Ho's name is on a lot of these
mortgages and I was just wondering if
you knew that that was the
case I'm going to have to um send send
you to my um um person at the firm and
uh you can speak to her about this no I
I would love to do that um and again
we're not saying that this has anything
to do with you necessarily we just we
would really like to speak with someone
at your bank because we want to know
kind of what the process is that's
letting let me give you let me give you
her name yeah that would be fantastic
her name uh
Casey
okay and uh her number is 646
okay okay thank you um okay yeah that
that's great
bye now we should have seen that coming
considering that it was old supervisor
hang-up but that's a far cry from the
reaction she had when she spoke to Mr
Robinson in Maine a few days prior to
our phone call
those according to my investigation
those properties are actually being used
as illegal marijuana growing operations
controlled by Chinese foreign Nationals
wondering if you had any knowledge of
that uh when you were originating the
loans oh they were oh really
they uh yeah yeah they're actually on a
Department of Homeland Security list
flagged as uh controlled by uh Asian
trans National organized
crime oh my
God so you had you had no knowledge when
you were originating those
loans no I never met those people oh my
God now of course they never got back to
us they passed us off to the chief
empowerment officer who's a py for the
higher
ups so once these operators set up shop
in Oklahoma they need help getting their
business off off the ground and to do so
they have to meet a series of Industry
regulations so according to Oklahoma law
licenses are available for Oklahoma
residents who are at least 25 years old
applicants must provide documents
establishing the applicant and the
members managers and board members if
applicable and 75% of the commercial
applicants ownership interests are
Oklahoma residents as required in the
Oklahoma medical marijuana and patient
protection act I yes the
patients forgot about that
[Music]
at least those Chinese slaves are
keeping these patients medicated that
last part by the way is crucial 75% of
the ownership must be Oklahoma residents
so how do Chinese Nationals operating on
behalf of crime syndicates who
presumably are not Oklahoma citizens
skirt the regulations well they have
helped from fixers and you had these
entities like I said these law firms
that would step up and say don't worry
about your 75% owner you pay us a fee
we're going to get you a license and
that will include we will find somebody
to put down as you're 75% owner so on
the surface you're going to look legit
uh so when they do a background and and
because that's all you need to get a
license in Oklahoma pay 2500 bucks and
pass the background which is no felony
in five years and so they made sure that
the person on the license as the 75%
primary owner is squeaky clean one such
person who uh jumped out on our radar
was a cons in officer out of Oklahoma
City called
Mama that's right
Mama fun to say easy person to dislike a
former Oklahoma grower writing uh to us
on the condition of anonymity actually
outlined the work that
Mama does something else I have learned
by doing business with the Chinese is
that they all or at least the ones I've
interacted with are connected with a
Chinese lawyer whose offices occupy an
entire floor in a high-rise office
building in downtown Oklahoma City I had
occasion to visit this office and while
there I asked the man what his business
was he indicated that he was basically a
fixer for the Chinese Growers if they
needed Services he would connect them
with local providers such as myself and
he provided help with compliance issues
that seems legit enough on the surface
but if I were seriously looking into
this issue this guy would be high on my
list to investigate every job I have
done for them I have been paid in
physical cash usually in American $20
bills it was also confirmed to us that
Mama was on the radar it'll never not be
fun to say of law enforcement in
Oklahoma so in March 2022 this same
company Mama filed a lawsuit against
shushin Chi for defamation now that
lawsuit identified the owner of mamama
consult LLC as one y ya Fu known by her
English name as Sona
Fu because that's very
English of Flushing Queens now when
looking into Fu we found she also owns a
residence
in edmit
Oklahoma right a record search of that
property turned up a mortgage that
mortgage was issued by none other
than Quantic bank and signed off by
Steven hoe the same loan agent attached
to m mulle property purchase of weed
farms in Maine and suspected weed
operations in
Oklahoma further investigation into Fu
English name also revealed that she is a
certified notary public so on October
24th 2023 uh Fu notorized a groundwater
usage permit application for JN
operations and owner xuii ni on
december24 Shu was arrested and charged
with illegal cultivation and drug
trafficking
now looking into Jane operations LLC we
also found that it was filed for by an
Oklahoma attorney named Matt Stacy Stacy
among other things is a decorated
veteran a state Senate candidate and he
was appointed by current Oklahoma
governor Kevin stit to head the state's
covid Response Team oh and Mr Stacy is
listed as the primary contact for 320
marijuana licenses or about 3 and a
half% of all marijuana licenses in oklah
and in February 2022 he was charged with
13 felony counts related to illicit
marijuana again if we legalize all of it
there will be
no illicit Market in an attempt to
obtain some kind of comment from Yi yau
directly um the team here traveled to
Mama's downtown Oklahoma City location
and it
got
spicy what
like not level like if it's you know the
level one to five on
takeout four you don't know to five
that's just they're just that's just to
harm you so it got to level four when we
caught up with Mrs Foo on a conference
call with her
employees oh hello yes hi hi is Miss Fu
in today Miss fu yeah Fu we have a a
scheduled appointment with
her
uh
is no is she not yeah we were supposed
to meet with her today no yeah we're
doing an investigation about the the
marijuana businesses that got shut down
and we found out that she was attached
to it so we wanted to get a comment from
her we're just curious to know her
relationship with Matt Stacy there's a
lot going on we're running an
investigation Stacy
I oh are you sure because we found that
you notorized a duck Mr to notorized the
document I I do a lot on notorized I do
clothing as well but I don't know my oh
okay that's interesting because we were
pointed in this direction for that H
what about Quantic Bank are you familiar
with Quantic bank at
all Quantic Bank out of
Queens May stepen
ho no the thing is way to Clos in Serv
oh okay right document got I if you ask
anybody you have to show him more
information cuz I don't really remember
that oh yeah that's understandable but
what about do you know stepen ho from
Quantic bank I think he did the mortgage
for
you Sten who Steven
ho I don't really know that is is oh
okay huh that's interesting because we
found stepen ho did the mortgage for you
and Quantic has done a lot of lending
here as well for um the marijuana
industry is there anybody that we could
talk to about this because it seems that
there's we know that this place is under
investigation so we are just curious who
we might be able to talk to I'm a y want
to talk to me yeah okay yeah that's
perfect if you could we're just very
curious to know um about your
relationship or Mama's relationship with
Quantic bank because they're also part
of this investigation and we're finding
that they have a relationship with mama
ma and the marijuana industry it seems
like there's a lot of connection going
on here I don't have any personal
relationship with a Quant at all so
you're not familiar with Quantic at all
talking so you've never met with a
Steven
hoe I don't know who that is okay that's
interesting what do you you have any I
don't do mortgage here no I know the
mortgage on your house though was signed
by Stephen H I have no idea who that is
though is there any way we can get your
phone number and we can follow up with
you with some questions we might have my
phone number is
405 yeah you ready that for me yeah
perfect okay and I'm sorry who's
speaking right now
yeah
okay2 so we don't do any mortgage
service and I don't know who that's even
is but I do know the right document and
I do sometimes I provide the
uh the de prire the de that's all my
Serv I don't really know who the back or
Ste okay yeah well we'd love to talk to
you about just how that came to your
desk we're not you know not insinuating
anything just curious but you said 405
0702 405 who are you guys by the way uh
go ahead yeah no go ahead no problem
we're we're journalists investigating
the story right now so there's there's a
lot of different investigations going on
that surround this whole thing that my
partner just kind of laid out for you
guys so we're just trying to get to the
bottom of a few things and you know we
have a lot of questions if if you can
help us that'd be great you can see I'm
very sick and I don't really have time
for
G so please leave me alone thank you
okay thank
you all right
well a
[Music]
change thank you you it
work y appreciate you now immediately
after that interaction a researcher on
this team found something that you would
consider straight from a Hollywood
script and not even necessarily one
that's been redacted for the Chinese
market now you remember how Miss Fu told
my reporters that she didn't really
know Matt Stacy and that she notorized
documents for a lot of
people that could be the case uh as it
turns out Google Street View has
excellent photographs of both Miss Fu's
Edmond residents as well as of JN
greenow a shuddered weed farm owned by
Shu J and fronted by Matt Stacy a
picture is worth 1,000 G now as you can
see the same twodo 28 robin's egg Jeep
Wrangler is at both locations and
according to Geico records that jeep is
registered to foo's Edmond address now
armed with this
information because you've heard that
knowledge is
power sometimes it is in this case it
was uh my team went back to see why Miss
Fu said she had no knowledge of things
she she clearly she clearly knows
what's hi all right we were just talking
to you upstairs okay yeah so we just
wanted to clarify something because we
came back and had a discussion and we
have no idea I have the do right here I
have no idea are you sure because it is
her address is Miss Fu's address I in
Edmond
Oklahoma so this right here on this
document we have it was signed for by W
Bank approved by Steven hoe who she says
she has no knowledge of am she I don't
know but she maybe can we get a number
from you oh thanks because we do have
photo evidence of her Jeep at an illicit
marijuana farm that she claimed to have
no knowledge of and the same Jeep parked
in front of her residence in Edmund
Oklahoma that was signed for by Steven
ho at quanum bank that was mortgage are
you
sure are you positive can we get her
number please we'd like to clarify this
we don't want to report things that
aren't
[Music]
true we back up and see El also
noteworthy of Foo she's just filled with
criminal nuggets is her phone number is
listed as the contact number for wangin
fanme a service provider that offers
full supervision services for overseas
students studying in America now the
site is new it was created on December
2023 and it advertises a
relationship seemingly official with the
University of Oklahoma College of
Aeronautics having our
suspicions we reached out to a
representative directly for the
University to see if there was any kind
of an official Foo connection um you
know I've never heard that name before
and I don't know why they'd be
advertising us because we're a kids
program yeah um based out of Norman
Oklahoma so um can you tell me what that
website is so I can look into it sure um
by the looks of it they just kind of
copy pasted your website's homepage onto
theirs um it's called wangin FME so it's
w a n g uhuh x i
n f a n s n m
me.com yeah well thank you so much for
doing that um I will definitely look
into that and I'll probably have to get
a legal involved after exhausting the
willingness of mamama
employees to talk we decided to contact
Steven hoe the man who signed Miss Fu's
mortgage and see what he had to say see
I'm a you know I'm a tax American and I
don't I'm not you know anyone that do
any illegal activities just so I have
this clear you don't know off the top of
your head you don't know y ya
Fu I do not it was it was a very busy
time in those last couple years so
um I do not know anyone specifically um
what was quantic's response when they
were made aware that so much of their
financing was leading was helping
facilitate this yeah I I uh you'd have
to ask them I don't know you know how
they reacted you know that that might
have been a PR level for them that I was
not part of okay so I I really don't
know yeah how much would you have to
look into each individual loan that you
were
issuing like about the perspective like
the like the quality control how much
would you have to look into the the
perspective borrower before you decide
or was it just kind of a numbers game
for
you um yeah you know you know L like
those two years for any experienced
originator we're having career
years so
um we were everyone was so busy right
there were just they were they were yeah
they were just you know taking
applications and you know double
checking that they qualified and and and
help them getting a loan uh you know in
hindsight now that you know this is you
know I don't know which person how many
people like hindsight now the question I
need to ask not that they'll be they'll
give me an honest answer if to ask those
extra questions by the way what are you
going to do with this property now to be
fair it does seem like ho was unaware of
exactly what Quantic was up to he may be
an idiot
but it also looks like Quantic
operated with the attitude of its best
not to ask
questions okay so let's back up we now
know that new york-based Quantic Bank
financed the purchase of multiple
properties in Oklahoma as well as
illicit weed farms in Maine all right
these mortgages are signed off by Ying
Chang Wang or Steven hoe these are the
loan Originators Quantic led by Steven
hoe also wrote the mortgage for Edmond
Oklahoma property purchased by Yi yaa Fu
who also has a property in Flushing
Queens The Hub of China's United States
drug Network now in
addition to being the primary contact
for a service provider to Chinese
students in America that may or may not
exist Yi yau is the owner of mam consult
LLC based out of Oklahoma City mamama
consult LLC helps Chinese Nationals
obtain marijuana grow licenses in
Oklahoma by helping them circumvent in
indry standards as chill as they may be
including the requirement that 75% of
the Farms must be owned by an Oklahoma
resident Miss Fu acts in this role
herself fu is a public notary she
notorized a groundwater usage permit
application for JN operations LLC and
Shu the farm has subsequently been shut
down and the owner arrested as of
December 28th 2023 JN operations has
listed as a primary contact one Matt
Stacy an Infamous Oklahoma attorney with
personal relationships with the governor
and point of contact for more than 300
marijuana farms in Oklahoma Stacy has
also been charged with 13 marijuana
related felonies so to sum this all up
Quantic loan money to multiple Chinese
Nationals in Oklahoma including the
owner of Mama consult yya Fu who on at
least one occasion worked hand in glove
with Oklahoma's most notorious weed
magnet Matt St AC to set up an illicit
marijuana farm that is now under seizure
order by the state of
[Music]
Oklahoma Okay so we've told you about
the operations the destruction and the
players on the ground but at the end of
the day there's one entity pulling the
real strengths and it's not a Crime Boss
it's not just a mortgage broker or even
a
bank the Chinese Communist party's
cooperation with the Triads has been
incredibly well documented and has
Foundation stemming from the Handover of
Hong Kong by Britain to China in the
late 1990s writing for the publication
foreign policy J Michael Cole describes
this Evolution um as it relates to the
relationship by the 1990s Triads were
well established in both Hong Kong and
Taiwan and the CCP had gone from seeing
them as a brutal opponent to a useful
tool after the Handover the relationship
evolved in what was now Chinese
territory Pro Beijing gangsters
threatened and on a few occasions
physically assaulted activists and the
few media Outlets that remained critical
of Beijing So Pro Beijing gangsters have
remained active in suppressing any type
of anti-communist Chinese sentiment
including in 2017 when Triads assaulted
a group of pro- Hong Kong democracy
protesters at the Hong Kong airport we
also know that the CCP and the Triad
work hand and glove when it comes to
moneya laundering for example in 2020 21
the commission of inquiry into money
laundering and BC revealed that a
Chinese National earning about 40,000 a
year decent income purchased $32 million
worth of real estate in Vancouver Canada
and we know that it's a country that's
good at math it doesn't add up a related
summon showed that between 2011 and 2020
Hong Kong depositors moved
$66
million into BC accounts unsurprisingly
these depositors were linked directly to
organized crime and the CCP with one
depositor being a member of China's
foreign influence program so that brings
us to our story right back we know these
operations connect far beyond Oklahoma
we know they have international
ties including the Mexican cartel a US
Treasury official tells NBC news that
Chinese criminal organizations are
operating in the US and now working with
Mexican cartels by helping them launder
money made from meth fenel and Other
Drugs these Chinese entities with direct
connections to the Communist Chinese
government facilitating drug tra namely
fentel okay for the Mexican cartels it's
such an Open
Secret that it took Center Stage
November 2023 in a meeting between Joe
Biden and xingping in San Francisco
Biden said that he and G got to restart
cooperation to encountering narcotics
they got to talk about the fenol crisis
and the production of those precursors
to fent and all those precursors the
chemicals that are produced in China so
the question becomes are these Chinese
crime organizations really operating
independently of the Chinese Communist
party after all it's kind of difficult
to believe that the world's largest
surveillance State could be so blind to
such large scale burning smelly
operations as it turns out Beijing isn't
blind maybe not the best peripheral
vision but not blind and in fact they're
utilizing these criminal organizations
for their own means here's a leaked
border patrol memo that laid out exactly
how profits from illicit marijuana
operations flow directly back to China
and of course these profits can be quite
uh lucrative it's immensely profitable
if you have slaves doing the work that's
kind of a big thing more slaves right
now on Earth than ever in recorded
history you can look it up you can use
my source or any Source available to you
because of situations like this now of
according to Mr Woodward at obn they've
intercepted
truckloads of marijuana worth at least
$28 million Mr Woodward went uh into
detail uh on the Chinese government's
involvement specifically in Oklahoma it
comes as a shock to me that these larg
scale organizations could be operating
in the United States in such a large
degree without some sort of at least
tacit approval from the Chinese
Communist Party have you is there any
link there that you've seen or identifi
where you at least see involvement or
kind of approval from the CCP is there
any indication of that at all well
there's 100% um evidence that the the
Chinese Communist party is absolutely
aware of everything that their citizens
are doing within the borders of their
country and our us borders uh there's no
doubt they they monitor everything they
monitor their people their activities
the M the movement of the money um it's
much like with the fenal crisis U you
know China publicly crack said they're
going to crack down on the the
exportation of fenal out of China but
privately they they've done nothing to
to stop it and they know exactly what's
happening and it's no different with
with the Chinese um communist party's
involvement in marijuana in the United
States this is well documented U and
I've seen other documentaries that have
aired where where one of the big parts
of the Chinese Communist Party one of
their their primary goals is one acquire
as much us land as you can and number
two acquire and and gather as much and
collect US currency as possible and and
that that's why people say why are they
involved in marijuana because it could
accomplishes both of those goals you
need thousands of acres of land
sometimes for just a few farms in places
like Oklahoma and it's an allash
business and 40 states have legalized it
so U that that's accomplishing their
goals and specifically talking about
Oklahoma I can't get into a lot of
details but I can tell you that we have
identified people who are considered
National Security risks tied to the
Chinese Communist Party identified on
Oklahoma Farms as among these these
people that come and check and monitor
uh the activities of the farms and the
workers themselves they are linked to
high ranking people within the Chinese
government um that have been that we
personally have identified here in
Oklahoma on these Farms now I'm not a a
Chinese National but this math adds up
we all know that China's been buying up
Farmland across the United States and
they've been securing troves of hard US
currency at least well I hope you know
if not now you know and even though
China claims it wants the world to
convert to their own currency the Yuan
they
reportedly have more than3 trillion
dollar in foreign currency that is off
the books they're Eddie hasling it
you're the one that did it yeah but if
you go around squealing on guys nobody's
going to like you to further understand
the Chinese Communist party's uh goals
here we reached out to John cacer a
former Cold War intelligence officer and
a special agent at the US Treasury who
told us this regarding direct links
between the CCP and transnational crime
you must understand that China is a
command State whether it be the fentanyl
trade or the online advertising for
illegal products organ harvesting
illicit tobacco counterfeiting which
represents about 2% of China's GDP
illicit fishing human trafficking none
of this could happen without the ccp's
consent Chinese actors in the United
States cannot be here without the
permission of the central government
what do they have to gain president XI
has publicly stated that the West is
declining and China is ascending
criminal activity has become part of
China's strategy to grow its power in
conjunction with its authoritarian
statecraft military buildup Espionage
theft deception trade loans debt traps
payoffs influence operations Etc to
structure a 21st century with Chinese
quote characteristics look the aim of
the CCP here is pretty clear xiin ping
has stated himself that he intends to
see the great
Rejuvenation of the Chinese nation and
we have internal CCP memos that outline
a strategy showing that this
Rejuvenation means displacing the
American order and
instead replacing it instituting
beijing's own so of course they would
want to own United States farms and of
course of course they would want to be
involved with the illicit marijuana
industry in Oklahoma but it's just one
tool that Beijing is using to enrich
itself and undermine the United States
but sometimes when the scope feels so
big you get lost in this game and forget
that there are real life consequences
for everyday Americans it's killing
absolutely killing the legitimate
industry as I said before the first two
years we probably had close to 3 4,000
farms and most of those were run by just
local people trying to make a go of it
so the market was already oversaturated
and then you have an influx of 5,000
more Farms that are we've linked back to
Mexican organized crime Chinese
organized crime that try to look
legitimate on the surface but they're
all criminal and they're growing for
$100 a pound they're going to undercut
legitimate Growers for sure yeah
legitimate Growers cannot compete
they're having to grow for $800 a pound
and they say I can barely make payroll
it's not exactly healthy or positive or
strengthening America to have this
happening uh right in our back yards uh
you know it's it's making the cost of
living far more expensive everywhere
it's destroying Main's housing stock
it's reducing our available housing
Supply increasing the price of
electricity it's bad for the environment
and oh by the way the the product that
they're producing is laced with
pesticides and fungicides it's not
tested it's not regulated it's not up
the standard of the legal product that
comes out of Maine and one of the one of
the fungicides that they use is called
Eagle 20 and it's approved for use on
your Tomatoes cuz you know it's going to
be okay if you eat it but when you smoke
it it turns into sin gas brother not
just uh they killed our American Dream
out here how I feel about it that's
that's what me and my wife saved up and
this was all in with our family to do
you know I was going to build a farm out
here at a house and live the rest of my
life and this is what I wanted to do
and I feel like I was wrong and those
are just the
Americans who know about it who've seen
the screw job take
place it could just as easily be
you when you have foreign
entities who have specifically stated
that their goal is to subvert the
Western American way of life and to do
so through operations within your own
country how many businesses have been
shattered how many people who've gone
missing how many how many years of
record border crossings with people and
our elected representative establishment
who do nothing about it at what point
does that damage you for all of the seen
damage there's unseen damage that can't
even begin to be
Quantified you feel it every day and
right now we're showing you what we can
verify but they're intangible variables
you can't put your finger on it why
because no one wants you to put your
finger on it you can't quantify it why
because no one wants you to quantify it
we know it's in the
trillions that's a starting
point we know it's in the
millions as far as
slaves we know it's in the hundreds of
thousands as far as illegal border
crossings every year we know that it's
in the hundreds of thousands to tens of
millions of of Acres as far as American
Farmland that you may never get
back we know it's in the billions of
dollars that was lost during Co
that was foisted Upon Us by
again to some degree and by some I mean
all degree the Communist Chinese
government and
complicit Representatives who weren't
looking out for
you we do what we can here we appreciate
your support we really do the Mud Club
undercover unit here the investigative
journalis none of this will ever happen
without your support hey take a guess
why why do you think we're not
monetizing any mainstream platform
the same reason that John Cena had to
apologize for acting like Taiwan even
existed it's a growing
Market with a very powerful government
who gets to determine winners and losers
with the world's most powerful companies
that you depend on every single day for
your daily Necessities to the
information that you can
consume we don't know exactly how deep
it goes but my God on the
surface it already sucks doesn't it John
[Music]
Cena
for